This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. On this week's episode, we're talking about backup plans. Research Akiti Milkman shares her study on why it's not always a good idea to have a plan B. It may make you less motivated to pursue your primary goals. Dan Pink is here for another round of stopwatch science. So these are glorious times for scholars who research moral hazard. And we invited Matthew McConaughey to talk about the importance of backup plans in the movie Interstellar.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹坦。在本周的节目中，我们将讨论备用计划。研究员凯蒂·米尔克曼分享了她的研究，探讨为什么有B计划并不总是件好事。这可能会让你对追求首要目标的动力不足。丹·平克带来了又一轮“秒表科学”。对研究道德风险的学者来说，这是辉煌的时刻。我们还邀请了马修·麦康纳来谈谈电影《星际穿越》中备用计划的重要性。
Some kind of vehicle, uh, space station, both, and I, how do you get it off the ground? That's why there's Plan B. But Matthew was a little busy, so we went with our Plan B and invited my friend Adam Cole from NPR Science Desk instead. Hello, having some real flashbacks to junior prom right now.
某种交通工具，呃，太空站，两者皆是，而我，你如何让它升空？这就是为什么要有B计划。但马修有点忙，所以我们启用了B计划，转而邀请了来自NPR科学桌的我的朋友亚当·科尔。你好，现在真的有一种回到初中舞会的感觉。
Just getting at him, you were always plan A. That sounds a lot better, yeah. Adam, just like the last time, I want you to listen to all the ideas in this episode and come up with a song that ties it all together. Do you think you could do that? Well, I'll try, but if I can't do it, do we have some sort of backup plan in place? Here's the thing, Adam, we don't. And to understand why we don't,
说真的，亚当，你一直都是A计划。听起来好多了，是的。亚当，就像上次一样，我希望你听完这集节目中的所有观点，然后创作一首将它们串联起来的歌。你觉得你能做到吗？嗯，我会试试，但如果我做不到，我们有没有准备什么备用计划？事情是这样的，亚当，我们没有。为了解为什么我们没有，
you need to listen to this next set of ideas. The research of Katie Milkman, at the University of Pennsylvania, was very interested in what happens when we have backup plans. Here she is. We have this sense that having a security blanket or a backup plan B is a strategy that will be helpful to us.
你需要听听接下来的一系列观点。宾夕法尼亚大学的凯蒂·米尔克曼的研究对我们有备用计划时会发生什么非常感兴趣。她来了。我们有一种感觉，拥有安全网或B计划是一种对我们有帮助的策略。
It'll make us more emotionally comfortable with our plans. It will make us feel like we're taking less risk. Katie Milkman tells me that there is a surprising downside to having that kind of safety net. Here she is again. It may make you less motivated to pursue your primary goals, so because you know that all your eggs aren't in this one basket, you may feel more confident and comfortable relaxing and letting up and not
它会让我们对自己的计划在情感上感到更舒适。它会让我们觉得自己承担的风险更小。凯蒂·米尔克曼告诉我，拥有这种安全网有一个令人惊讶的缺点。她又来了。这可能会让你对追求首要目标的动力不足，因为你知道并非所有的鸡蛋都放在同一个篮子里，你可能会感到更有信心、更舒适，从而放松下来、懈怠，不再
pushing as hard toward your primary goal, since you know things will be okay, you can always go with your backup plan. They used a couple of different methods to figure this out. The first method, which absolutely does not prove cause and effect, but does provide some tantalizing evidence, was to simply survey people in a train station. So Adam, when Katie Milkman told me that the first part of her study was at a train station, we decided we would try and replicate this ourselves, and we ran down to Union Station
那么努力地去追求你的首要目标，既然你知道事情会好起来的，你总是可以选择你的备用计划。他们用了几种不同的方法来弄清楚这一点。第一种方法当然不能证明因果关系，但确实提供了一些诱人的证据，那就是简单地在火车站采访人们。所以亚当，当凯蒂·米尔克曼告诉我她的研究的第一部分是在火车站进行的，我们决定自己尝试复制这一点，于是我和一位制作人跑到了华盛顿特区的联合车站，
in Washington, D.C., a producer and I, and ran a little experiment ourselves. What is your name? Fiona. While walking through Union Station, we came across Fiona. She's a young woman from Kenya who was in Washington visiting her family. Her Romanian boyfriend was down the hall buying bus tickets to New York. Fiona and Razvan are planning on moving to the United Kingdom together but it's challenging for them to get the right visa. Plan A is that you just get the visa and get to the UK.
自己做了一个小实验。你叫什么名字？菲奥娜。在穿过联合车站时，我们遇到了菲奥娜。她是一位来自肯尼亚的年轻女性，当时在华盛顿探亲。她的罗马尼亚男朋友正在大厅买去纽约的车票。菲奥娜和拉兹万计划一起搬到英国，但获得正确的签证对他们来说是个挑战。A计划是你们直接拿到签证去英国。
And get a job there. And get a job there, it really goes there. What's Plan B? Plan B is maybe Germany or something? Close enough, because I have family in Germany. So it might be easier to be German. You are keeping a lot of options open. Lots of options, because with visas you never know. So I need like Plan A to Z.
并在那里找份工作。并在那里找份工作，事情确实会这样发展。什么是B计划？B计划也许是德国什么的？差不多吧，因为我在德国有家人。所以去德国可能会更容易。你留了许多备选项。很多备选项，因为签证这事你永远说不准。所以我需要从A到Z的各种计划。
So here's the question. When you have so many options, do you think that it actually distracts you from focusing on Plan A? That having Plan B, CD, E, F, G, that it actually makes it less focused on Plan A? Because you have all those other things at the back of your head. I'm very focused on Plan A, hoping it works. But you know, I'm trying to be pessimistic so that I'm very focused on Plan A, hoping it works, but you know I'm trying to be pessimistic so that I'm not disappointed in Plan A doesn't work out. Okay, full back plan, full back plan.
所以问题是。当你拥有这么多选项时，你觉得它真的会分散你对A计划的注意力吗？拥有B、C、D、E、F、G计划，真的会让你对A计划不那么专注吗？因为你脑海深处还有所有这些别的事情。我非常专注於A计划，希望它能成功。但你知道，我试着持悲观态度，这样我就能非常专注于A计划，希望它能成功，但你知道我试着持悲观态度，这样我就不会在A计划行不通时感到失望。好吧，兜底计划，兜底计划。
It just makes me more calm. In case of anything going wrong in Plan A, I know I have a busy year. So with everything in my life, I always have, you know, other plans on the site. You have backup plans. Yes. Let me backup plans? Yes. Let me ask you a question. Has there ever been a time in your life when you've not had a plan B or C because you've just said,
这只是让我更冷静。万一A计划出现任何问题，我知道我有一年很忙。所以对于我生活中的一切，我总是，你知道，在旁边有别的计划。你有备用计划。是的。让我备用计划？是的。我问你一个问题。你生命中可曾有过这样的时候，你没有B计划或C计划，因为你说过，
this is the only thing that I want. There's nothing else that's going to be acceptable. And therefore, I'm not going to have plan B, CD, or E. I'm just just planning and nothing else. For me, no, I think my boyfriend works with that. I mean, he just works with one plan. I'm the one who's trying to teach him how to have millions of plans inside. I mean, even with boyfriend, I really so.
这是我唯一想要的东西。没有什么是可以接受的。因此，我不会有B、C、D或E计划。我只是在规划，别的什么都不做。对我来说，没有，我想我男友就是按那个来的。我是说，他只按一个计划行事。我是那个试图教他如何在心里准备几百万个计划的人。我是说，即使对男朋友也是如此，真的。
I hope I don't have to go to Plan B and see if it's good to have a plan. You know, okay, if we don't work out, this is what I'll do, you know. Your boyfriend, before he comes, before he's here, let me ask you. So if he doesn't work out, what's the plan B? Every girl has People that maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe every girl even she does You love them person, but something doesn't work out. There's that guy possible possible possible Everyone has that I don't know about men But you actually have this list of people in your head
我希望我不要用到B计划，看看有计划是不是挺好的。你知道，好吧，如果我们行不通，这就是我要做的，你知道。你的男朋友，在他来之前，在他来到这里之前，让我问问你。所以如果他行不通，B计划是什么？每个女孩都有……可能，可能，可能，可能每个女孩，甚至当她深爱着一个人，但有些事情行不通时。都有那种人，可能，可能，可能每个人都有，我不知道男人是怎么样的，但你脑海里确实有这样一个名单
Possibly and you basically said this person right now that you're aware this is 80% But there's a 75% chance or someone Some of them even 40% but still in the line. Yes, you keep them in the line better than zero You know, yes Is this your birthday? Yes We were just talking about NPR reporters and we're doing a story that looks at how people make plans and how they think about their plans.
可能，基本上你觉得这个人现在你意识到这是80% 但有75%的概率或者某个人 有的甚至40%但依然在候选名单里。是的，你把他们留在候选名单里总比零好 你知道，yes 这是你的生日吗？是的 我们刚刚在谈论NPR的记者，我们在做一个故事，探讨人们是如何制定计划的，以及他们是如何看待自己的计划的。
And she was talking about the different strategies and approaches that you both have in your personalities. So when you're making plans, do you often have a plan B and say, if this doesn't work out, that's going to work out? She was saying that you just are very focused on the things that you want to do. Yeah. This is, I don't want to be in a situation when I feel vulnerable, especially in another country when I travel, if it's a traveling plan. So every time I look at other options, the worst
她在谈论你们两人的性格中不同的策略和方法。所以当你制定计划时，你经常会有B计划，并说，如果这个行不通，那个就会行不通吗？她说你只是非常专注于你想做的事。是的。这是，我不想处于一种感到脆弱的状况，尤其是在另一个国家旅行时，如果是旅行计划的话。所以我每次都会看其他选项，最坏
case scenario. Oh, so you actually do keep options? Yeah, but it's more focused on planning. Yeah, I focus because I also don't accept failure. My plan, everything has to go according to the plan. So in general, for the big things in your life, not when you know how to get to Philadelphia and which bus to get, but for the big things in your life where you're going to work and who you're going to marry and do you actually have very clear ideas of what you want and say this is what's going to happen and I'm going to stick to that. I'm trying to impose this philosophy of life I think before I believed in more natural and things just happened,
的情况。哦，所以你确实保留了选项？是的，但它更专注于规划。是的，我专注于规划，因为我也不能接受失败。我的计划，一切都必须按计划进行。所以总的来说，对于你生活中的大事，不是你知道怎么去费城以及坐哪辆公交车这种事，而是对于你生活中的大事，比如你要去哪里工作，你要和谁结婚，你是否真的对你想要的东西有非常清晰的想法，并说这就是将要发生的事情，我将坚持到底。我试图把这种生活哲学强加给自己，我想以前我相信更自然的事情，事情顺其自然发生，
but I am thinking lately I took this approach. I need to know what I want because otherwise it would not just come to me. I need to be to step up, take decisions and go with it, not let it just come with karma. So nowadays I feel I'm imposing myself this philosophy of knowing what I want. I want this, why do I want this and stick to it. So in terms of romantic life, do you have a plan B if she doesn't work out? Or are you saying this is the one and I'm not going to think about any other plans and options. What's the good question? Very good question.
但最近我在思考，我采取了这种方法。我需要知道我想要什么，否则它不会凭空降临到我身上。我需要站出来，做决定并坚持下去，而不是让它随缘。所以现在我觉得我在把这种知道自己想要什么的哲学强加给自己。我想要这个，我为什么想要这个，然后坚持下去。那么在感情生活方面，如果她行不通，你会有B计划吗？还是你会说这就是真命天女，我不会去想任何其他的计划和选项。这是个好问题吗？非常好的问题。
I don't have a plan B. I'm sticking to plan A. I'm sticking to my decision and I'll make it work. If I start with a plan B in a relationship, I think he's... yeah I'm thinking of the worst case scenario but alcohol would get me through that. I don't need another plan B but now I'm sticking to plan A because I think I'm doing a much more decision. At the moment I hope I'm doing it. So I'm fascinated because you're actually saying that having a plan B can affect how much you focus on planning. I'm not planning.
我没有B计划。我坚持A计划。我坚持我的决定，我会让它行得通。如果我在一段感情中从B计划开始，我想他是……是的，我在考虑最坏的情况，但酒精会帮我度过难关。我不需要另一个B计划，但现在我坚持A计划，因为我认为我做出了更好的决定。目前我希望我正在这样做。所以我很着迷，因为你实际上是在说，有一个B计划会影响你对规划的专注程度。我没有在规划。
That's why I guess maybe first when I talked about focusing and when I'm traveling maybe I look like a control freak. But I also think plan B makes you relax and think yeah whatever, let's just have a drink and if we miss the bus, we take the second one. Let's just not give her all the attention because if it's not going to work, there's plenty of fish in the sea. But this will just make you relax and maybe not focus enough because the Plan B is also comfortable. Plan B is always the comfort zone. You go back there, plenty of buses, there are plenty of girls, there's plenty of this.
这就是为什么我想也许最开始当我谈到专注时，当我旅行时，我看起来像个控制狂。但我也认为B计划会让你放松，觉得管他的，我们去喝一杯吧，如果我们错过了这辆车，我们可以坐下一辆。我们不要把所有的注意力都放在这上面，因为如果行不通，天涯何处无芳草。但这只会让你放松，也许不够专注，因为B计划也很舒服。B计划永远是舒适区。你回到那里，有很多公交车，有很多女孩，有很多这个。
It's back to the comfort zone where you don't have to step up, look at the time, bring flowers, give kisses. Well, I think that Razzvan has just written the song himself. That was very poetic. But what's the science behind that? So Adam Katie Milkman wanted to find out the evidence as well. very poetic. But what's the science behind that? So Adam Katie Milkman wanted to find out the evidence as well.
回到了舒适区，在那里你不需要站出来，看看时间，送鲜花，给亲吻。嗯，我想拉兹万刚刚自己写了首歌。那非常富有诗意。但背后的科学依据是什么呢？所以亚当，凯蒂·米尔克曼也想找出证据。非常富有诗意。但背后的科学依据是什么呢？所以亚当，凯蒂·米尔克曼也想找出证据。
She decided to take her research out of the train station and into the laboratory. And what we did is we gave participants a shared goal. They all had the same goal, which was to achieve high performance on a task we designed to them. And in one study, we told them that if they achieved that high performance, they would get to finish up five minutes early.
她决定把研究从火车站搬进实验室。我们做的是，给参与者一个共同的目标。他们都有相同的目标，即在我们为他们设计的一项任务中取得高性能。在一项研究中，我们告诉他们，如果他们实现了高性能，他们就可以提前五分钟完成。
So they'd get the same pay that they were expecting to receive, but they'd have five extra minutes in their day to do with whatever they pleased. And one group, we asked them before they pursued this task to think about another way that they could save five minutes today if they didn't achieve the goal of getting five minutes back in our study. A second group we asked to simply brainstorm about what one could do with five minutes to hold brainstorming constant, and then a third group was a control group and they had no initial instructions they just began the task. And what we found is that the group had thought about a backup
所以他们会得到他们期望得到的报酬，但他们的一天中会有额外的五分钟来做他们喜欢的事情。在一个组中，我们要求他们在进行这项任务之前，考虑另一种今天可以节省五分钟的方法，如果他们在我们的研究中没有实现获得五分钟的目标的话。第二组，我们要求他们简单地头脑风暴一下用五分钟可以做些什么，以保持头脑风暴的一致性，然后第三组是对照组，他们没有任何初步说明，直接开始任务。我们发现，想过备用
plan about another way that they could save five minutes today, achieve significantly less success on the task we assign them. They worked less hard, they solved fewer puzzles, and this was significantly fewer than people in either of our control groups. So this is actually a disturbing finding in some ways, because it really suggests that this very normal and perhaps even wise course of action, which is to have a plan B to have a safety net when you're marking on something difficult and dangerous, really has a downside.
计划（即今天可以节省五分钟的另一种方法）的那组人在我们分配的任务上取得的成功明显更少。他们工作不那么努力，解出的谜题也更少，这比我们任何一个对照组的人都要少得多. 所以在某些方面，这实际上是一个令人不安的发现，因为它确实表明，这种非常正常甚至可能是明智的做法——也就是在着手进行困难和危险的事情时准备一个B计划，拥有一张安全网——确实有其弊端。
I mean, there's a real tension here. That's right. I think there is a really important tension here. And again, what I don't want to say is that it means we should be done with backup plans because they provide real value. And all we're trying to show here is that there's a downside we might not be appreciating and that we should try to find ways to stay equally motivated even if we do want to provide a safety net for ourselves. How do we go about doing that? I mean this has been found in similar studies if you look at people wearing helmets for example when they go
我的意思是，这里存在着真正的张力。没错。我认为这里确实存在着非常重要的张力。再说一次，我并不是说这意味着我们应该抛弃备用计划，因为它们提供了真正的价值。我们在这里试图展示的只是，有一个我们可能没有意识到的缺点，我们应该努力寻找方法来保持同等的动力，即使我们确实想为自己提供一张安全网。我们该怎么做呢？我的意思是，如果在类似的研究中，比如你看人们骑自行车时戴
bicycling they take more risks and as they're bicycling if you ask people to wear seatbelts and cars, they now drive a little bit faster than if they were not wearing seatbelts. And I don't think, as you're saying, the implication is we should eliminate seatbelts and ask people not to wear helmets, but how do we get around this human tendency to say, I'm protected, and therefore I can take a chance. That's an absolutely fabulous question. I think it's the big question that the study raises. And unfortunately, we don't know the answer, but I do think awareness is always a good start.
头盔，他们会承担更多的风险；如果在汽车里让人系上安全带，他们现在开车会比不系安全带时开得快一点。正如你所说，这并不意味着我们应该取消安全带并要求人们不要戴头盔，但是我们如何克服人类这种“我有保护，所以我可以冒险”的倾向呢？这是一个绝对绝妙的问题。我认为这是这项研究提出的重大问题。不幸的是，我们不知道答案，但我确实认为意识到这一点总是一个好的开始。
So recognizing that there is this downside, that there is this risk of feeling too comfortable, feeling too confident, at least hopefully that can begin to combat it. I'm wondering in your own life, Kitty, do you make backup plans? I absolutely make backup plans. Give me an example of backup plans that you make. Oh gosh, that's a good question. I'm trying to think of my latest backup plan. So Ghaschen was a doctoral student here at the University of Pennsylvania at the Wharton School and she was preparing to go on the academic job market, hoping to find a fabulous faculty job. And she came into my office and said she was a bit worried about having a backup plan,
因此，认识到存在这种缺点，存在感到过于舒适、过于自信的风险，至少希望这能开始克服它。凯蒂，我想知道在你自己的生活中，你会制定备用计划吗？我绝对会制定备用计划。给我举一个你制定的备用计划的例子。哦天哪，这是个好问题。我在想我最近的备用计划。加申曾是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的一名博士生，她正准备进入学术就业市场，希望能找到一份极好的教职工作。她走进我的办公室，说她有点担心制定备用计划，
making a plan B in case she didn't get that job because she was worried it might demotivate her. Maybe one interesting implication is to think about whether or not you can outsource the job of backup plan. So as a student's advisor, for instance, perhaps they can focus solely on the primary plan of getting a job and let the advisor worry about the backup plan of where we'll find them a postdoctoral scholarship if they don't find
万一找不到那份工作就准备一个B计划，因为她担心这可能会打击她的积极性。也许一个有趣的启示是考虑你是否可以外包制定备用计划这项工作。例如，作为学生的导师，也许他们可以专注于找工作这一首要计划，而让导师去操心如果找不到
a faculty position. Maybe that's the best of both worlds. The students today is motivated and feels that they only have a plan A, no plan B, but the advisor's taking care of offsetting the risk by worrying about the plan B in the background. I think for this plan to work, you have to have an advisor that sends signals that they may be unreliable. And that would send a message that the advisor actually can't be trusted to come up with a proper backup plan,
教职岗位就在哪里为他们找到博士后奖学金这样的备用计划。也许这是两全其美的办法。今天的学生很有动力，觉得自己只有A计划，没有B计划，而导师则通过在后台操心B计划来承担化解风险的工作。我认为要让这个计划奏效，你必须有一个会发出不可靠信号的导师。这会传达出这样一种信息：这位导师其实并不值得信赖，无法拿出一个合适的备用计划，
which would motivate you to really focus on your primary goal. That's right, or you could simply have an advisor who's very quiet and doesn't signal one way or the other, and hopefully that will provide enough uncertainty that the student will work very, very hard. Thank you so much for talking with me today. My pleasure, thank you. So Shunker, have you been coming up with a backup plan secretly in case I fail? You know, Adam, I think the point of Katie Merkman's research is I shouldn't tell you if I have a backup plan
这会促使你真正专注于你的首要目标。没错，或者你完全可以找一个非常安静、不表态的导师，希望这能提供足够的不确定性，让学生非常非常努力地工作。非常感谢今天和我交谈。不客气，谢谢你。那么香卡，万一我失败了，你是不是一直在暗中制定备用计划？你知道，亚当，我认为凯蒂·米尔克曼研究的重点是我不应该告诉你我是否有备用计划，
because if I do, it's going to make you slack off and think that you have a safety net. So, absolutely not, Adam. Wow, my heart rate is rising as we speak. I guess I'll furiously take more notes. Wonderful. Now, we're going to take a short break. When we come back, I'm going to play a game of stopwatch science with my friend Daniel Pink. Dad and I will talk about a phenomenon called moral hazard. And the idea of moral hazard is that when you think you have a safety net, when you know that you have a backup plan, a plan B,
因为如果我这么做了，会让你懈怠并认为自己有一张安全网。所以，绝对没有，亚当。哇，我说话的时候心率都在上升。我想我要疯狂地记更多笔记了。太好了。现在，我们要休息一小会儿。回来后，我和我的朋友丹尼尔·平克将玩一局“秒表科学”游戏。丹和我将讨论一个名为“道德风险”的现象。道德风险的概念是，当你认为自己有一张安全网，当你明知自己有一个备用计划、一个B计划时，
you will take plan A less seriously, and as a result, all talks about things happen. Welcome to another edition of Stopwatch Science. I'm joined by Senior Stopwatch Science correspondent Daniel Pink. Hi, Dan. Hey, Shankar. Now, in addition to his role here on the Hidden Brain, Dan is also an author and a commentator. In Stop What Science, Dan and I challenge each other to present two pieces of research
你对待A计划就不会那么认真，结果，所有关于事情的讨论都会发生。欢迎收看又一期的《秒表科学》。加入我的是高级秒表科学记者丹尼尔·平克。嗨，丹。嗨，香卡。现在，除了在《隐藏的大脑》中担任角色外，丹还是一位作家和评论员。在《秒表科学》中，丹和我互相挑战，各自在不到一分钟的时间内呈现两项研究。
in under a minute each. Today, we're presenting studies about moral hazard. This is the idea that safety nets can sometimes cause us to take unnecessary risks, they change our behavior. There's no safety net here on Stop What Science, just a timer timer and a buzzer Dan can you tell me what sound I'm gonna hear if I exceed my one minute well. I've chosen the old car horn sound like this That sounds a little like a rooster doesn't it? I have decided that the sound that I'm gonna play for Dan when he exceeds his time is this What is that that's the sound of a chimpanzee, Dan. Okay. Thank you. All right.
今天，我们将介绍关于道德风险的研究。这个观点是，安全网有时会让我们承担不必要的风险，它们改变了我们的行为。这里没有安全网，只有计时器、定时器和蜂鸣器。丹，你能告诉我如果我超时会听到什么声音吗？我选了老式汽车喇叭的声音，像这样。那听起来有点像公鸡，不是吗？我决定当我超时时为丹播放的声音是这个。那是什么？那是黑猩猩的声音，丹。好的。谢谢。好了。
Dan Pink, your first minute starts right now. So these are glorious times for scholars who research moral hazard. There's nothing like a financial crisis. It's really the full employment act for moral hazard scholars, including Michael Acklin and Andreas Kern, while one is from Pitt, one is from Georgetown, and they did something really interesting. They had a theory that they decided to back up looking at some numbers, and they found a ghost straight to the punch line, that if you want to predict which countries are going to have a financial crisis,
丹·平克，你的第一分钟从现在开始。所以对研究道德风险的学者来说，这是辉煌的时刻。没有什么比金融危机更棒的了。这简直是道德风险学者的全就业法案，其中包括迈克尔·阿克林和安德烈亚斯·科恩，一个来自匹兹堡大学，一个来自乔治城大学，他们做了一件非常有趣的事。他们有一个理论，决定通过观察一些数据来支持它，他们发现了一个直奔主题的结论：如果你想预测哪些国家会发生金融危机，
look to see where US troops are deployed. Now, the reason for this is once again moral hazard the thinking is that hey if there troops in a particular country and the country goes south financially big brother uncle sam is going to step up and bail the country out now they also tested something they say well you wait maybe we put troops in countries that are at risk of financial crisis not the same come on this is so interesting i'm actually going to let you go on keep going what troops in countries that are at risk of financial crisis uh... not the same come on this is so interesting i'm actually gonna let you go on keep going we do we put troops in places that are risk of financial stability and the
看看美军部署在哪里。现在，原因依然是道德风险。人们的想法是，嘿，如果某个国家有美军，而这个国家财政状况变坏，老大哥山姆大叔就会站出来拯救这个国家。现在他们还测试了另一种说法，他们说，等等，也许我们把美军部署在面临金融危机风险的国家，而不是……等一下，这太有趣了，我实际上要让你继续说下去。把美军部署在面临金融危机风险的国家，等等，不是……等一下，这太有趣了，我实际上要让你继续说下去。我们确实把美军部署在金融稳定性有风险的地方，
answer is no because there are other markers when u.s. troops go there that actually indicate financial help what it suggests is that when we deploy troops out there it makes countries say hey we're protected we can take some risks and that's pretty much to stand a definition of moral risks. And that's pretty much the standard definition of moral hazard. You got it. I think that's pretty amazing, Dan. Thank you. So speaking of moral hazard, I'm going to turn on my stop watch here, and I'm
答案是并没有，因为当美军去那里时，还有其他迹象表明这实际上有财务帮助。这表明，当我们向那里部署军队时，会使国家说：嘿，我们有保护了，我们可以冒一些险，这几乎就是道德风险的标准定义。这几乎就是道德风险的标准定义。答对了。丹，我觉得这太惊人了。谢谢。说到道德风险，我要在这里打开我的秒表，
going to give you one minute. Now remember, the car horn will sound if you exceed your one minute. So get ready, right? Now. Alright, I'm going to be talking about bicycles and bicycle helmets and a very interesting experiment that was run in England some years ago. This is a study by Ian Walker who's in the Department of Psychology at the University of Bath or Bath. I'm not quite sure how they pronounce it. Anyway, what he did was he rode on a stretch of highway either with his helmet on or with his helmet off and then measured using a camera how close cars came to him
给你一分钟时间。现在记住，如果你超过一分钟，汽车喇叭就会响起。所以准备好，对吧？现在。好的，我要谈谈自行车和自行车头盔，以及几年前在英国进行的一项非常有趣的实验。这是伊恩·沃克的一项研究，他在巴斯大学心理学系（或者叫巴思，我不太确定他们是怎么发音的）。总之，他做的是：他戴着头盔或不戴头盔骑车穿过一段公路，然后用相机测量汽车靠近他的距离，
When he was wearing the helmet and when he was not wearing the helmet and what moral hazard predicts is that when he seems to be Protected because he's wearing a helmet Car drivers feel like they can take more risks because they feel that if I get close enough and he topples over He's not gonna die. He's wearing a helmet. And that's exactly what he found. When he was wearing a helmet, car drivers actually came closer to him, they drove closer. One of the interesting things he also found
无论他戴着头盔还是不戴头盔。道德风险预测的是，当他因为戴着头盔而显得受到保护时，汽车司机觉得他们可以承担更多风险，因为他们觉得如果我靠得足够近而他摔倒了，他不会死的，他戴着头盔。而这正是他所发现的。当他戴着头盔时，汽车司机确实靠得更近了，他们开得更近了。他发现的有趣的事情之一是，
is that when he wore a woman's wig, fewer people came close to him because they had the stereotype that women drivers, or women, women, they honked at him because he was wearing a wig. That's probably exactly what they did. But in this case, they honked at him because he was wearing a wig. That's probably exactly what they did. But in this case, they honked from some distance because their stereotype was women bicyclists
当他戴着女式假发时，靠近他的人反而更少了，因为他们有一种成见，认为女司机，或者女人，女人……他们对按喇叭是因为他戴着假发。这可能正是他们做的。但在这种情况下，他们从一定距离外按喇叭，因为他们的刻板印象是骑自行车的女性
were a little less stable than male bicyclists. Very interesting. So I guess Shankar's messaged all your kids out there is, don't wear a helmet, just put on a woman's wig. I'm not sure I would say that, but I'm not going to say more on that because I know Dan is just trying to buy time instead of paying attention to the fact that his one minute starts right now.
比骑自行车的男性稍微不稳定一些。非常有趣。所以我想香卡给你们所有孩子的信息是，不要戴头盔，只要戴上一顶女式假发。我不敢说这就是我的意思，但我不会再多说了，因为我知道丹只是在试图争取时间，而不是去注意他的倒计时从现在开始已经开始了。
Okay, so we talked about Uncle Sam. Now we're going to talk about in even higher power, God. There's some great research out of Stanford showing that when people hear references to God, they're willing to take bigger risks, but only certain kinds of risks. So here's what they did. They said to people, do you want for a fee, stare into this bright light that might harm your eyes? People who were reminded of God beforehand were more likely to do it. Now, they also did tested this with things that had moral content to them. So they said, do you want to learn how to bribe people?
好吧，我们谈到了山姆大叔。现在我们要谈谈一个更高权力的存在——上帝。斯坦福大学有一些很棒的研究表明，当人们听到对上帝的引用时，他们愿意承担更大的风险，但只限于某些类型的风险。所以他们是这样做的：他们对人们说，你愿不愿意付费盯着这个可能会伤害你眼睛的强光？事先被提醒过上帝的人更有可能这样做。现在，他们还对具有道德内容的事情进行了测试。所以他们说，你想学习如何贿赂别人吗？
Do you want to learn how to parasail people? Do you want to learn how to parasail? And when people were faced with the opportunity to learn how to bribe people, something that had moral content, they were actually less likely to take that risk. So what this shows is that when it comes to physical risk, not anything that involves values, that being exposed to God, seeing things like, in God we trust, seeing something like the Ten Commandments can make people chirp like a chimpanzee. But that was really interesting. So, because people feel protected, people feel protected by God, so they'll take more risk.
你想学习如何玩滑翔伞吗？你想学习如何玩滑翔伞吗？当人们面临学习如何贿赂别人（具有道德内容的事情）的机会时，他们实际上更不容易去冒那个险。所以这表明，当涉及到身体风险、不涉及任何价值观的事情时，接触到上帝，看到诸如“我们信仰上帝”之类的话，看到十诫之类的事物，会让人们像黑猩猩一样鸣叫。但那真的很有趣。所以，因为人们感到被保护，人们感到受到上帝的保护，所以他们会承担更多的风险。
Now, Shankar, I have to say in this case, you're not protected by God, or by the United States military, or by a wig. So you are all on your own, starting right now. I'm happy to report that the study that I'm just about to tell Dan is going to destabilize him to the extent that he's probably going to forget about the stopwatch. Okay. Because it has to do with how parents with college going kids behave and Dan has kids who are just about ahead off to college. And this is
现在，香卡，我不得不说在这种情况下，你没有受到上帝、美国军方或假发的保护。所以从现在开始，你得完全靠你自己了。我很高兴地向大家报告，我正要告诉丹的那项研究将极大地动摇他，以至于他可能会把秒表的事忘得精光。好的。因为它与家里有上大学孩子的父母的行为有关，而丹的孩子正准备上大学。这是
researched by Laura Hamilton who looks at what the effect is of parents paying for their children when they go to college. And what Laura Hamilton finds is that the more money parents pay for their kids, the less kids are required to sort of stand on their own in college, the worse the kids perform in terms of their GPA. It's not a huge effect, but what it finds is that when kids don't have to feel like their performance in college is actually on them, that there's somebody who's carrying them,
劳拉·汉密尔顿的研究，她研究的是父母为上大学的孩子付学费会产生什么影响。劳拉·汉密尔顿发现，父母为孩子花的钱越多，孩子在大学里独立面对困难的要求就越少，孩子的平均绩点（GPA）表现就越差。这并不是一个巨大的影响，但研究发现，当孩子们不必觉得自己在大学里的表现完全取决于自己，觉得有人在支持他们、
that someone who's gonna give them money, it makes them say, I'm just gonna take it easy, I'm gonna go to the bar, I'm just gonna hang out with my friends, I'm gonna pay less attention to my study. So I don't know how this is gonna change your behavior of these over your kids, Dan, but I'm gonna tell you that it might be a good idea just to cut your kids off, just like you're cutting me off right now.
有人会给他们钱时，这会让他们说：我要放轻松点，我要去酒吧，我要和朋友闲逛，我会更少关注我的学业。所以，我不知道这会如何改变你对待孩子的行为，丹，但我得告诉你，像你现在切断我的发言一样，断掉你孩子的经济来源可能是一个好主意。
Yeah, wow, that's actually quite fascinating. It makes me want to call my daughter and say, Sophia, it's been nice knowing you, but next fall, you're completely on your own. Good luck. I'm just trying to avoid moral hazard, darling. If you do that then, just make sure you didn't tell her the idea came from me.
哇，这其实挺迷人的。这让我想给我的女儿打电话说：“索菲亚，很高兴认识你，但从今年秋天开始，你得完全靠你自己了。祝你好运。”我只是想避免道德风险，亲爱的。如果你那样做的话，确保别告诉她这个主意是从我这儿听来的。
No, I won't. moral hazard, darling. If you do that then, just make sure you didn't tell the idea came from me. No, I won't. I'm back in the studio now with Adam Cole, producer, reporter, extraordinary from NPR Science Desk, and we've challenged Adam to come up with a song that stitches all the ideas in this podcast episode together. Adam, have you gotten any ideas? I've written down the downside to safety nets, lack of focus on primary goals,
不，我不会的。道德风险，亲爱的。如果你那样做的话，确保别告诉她这个主意是从我这儿听来的。不，我不会的。现在我回到了录音室，和来自NPR科学桌的制作人、杰出记者亚当·科尔在一起，我们向亚当发起挑战，让他创作一首将这期播客中的所有观点缝合在一起的歌。亚当，你有什么灵感吗？我写下了安全网的缺点、对首要目标缺乏专注，
the Kenya Romaniah, Germany, UK, couple, moral hazard, plenty of girls, plenty of buses. Writing a song is going to be a breeze for you. That's right, I'm just going to go back to the skunk bear cave and will see what i come up alright everyone adam is now out of the skunk bear cave was this a success i well i came up with something i know that you're a huge fan of pop punk and so of course famously so what we've got here is a pop punk garage band entitled Moral Hazard with two Zs. Hazard with two Zs, I love it. I don't need a plan B.
肯尼亚、罗马尼亚、德国、英国情侣，道德风险，到处是女孩，到处是公交车。写首歌对你来说应该是小菜一碟。没错，我这就回臭鼬熊洞看看我能想出什么来。好了各位，亚当现在从臭鼬熊洞出来了。这算成功吗？我……我想出了一些东西。我知道你是个流行朋克狂热粉，所以当然这是众所周知的。我们这里有一个名为“Moral Hazard”（道德风险，两个Z）的流行朋克车库乐队。Hazard有两个Z，我喜欢。我不需要B计划。
I say it no way I don't need the security. My old man won't pay for university, And Uncle Sam won't prop up my economy. No backup plan, those backups can distract me from my goal today. No safety, not my out of bed begins and ends with A. I don't need no plan B, no plan B, I don't need no plan B Yeah, yeah, it's not risk free, but it's a good philosophy I don't need no plan B, no plan B
我说没门，我不需要安全感。老爸不肯为大学买单，山姆大叔也不来支撑我的经济。没有备用计划，那些备选会分散我今天追逐目标的注意力。没有安全网，我的出路始于A终于A。我不需要什么B计划，不需要B计划，我不需要什么B计划。是的，是的，这并非全无风险，但这是个好哲学。我不需要什么B计划，不需要B计划。
When I bike, don't wear a helmet on my head Cause I like to wear this wig instead I realize I'm no maximum connoisseur. I fly from Kenya to the UK. Around the world there's lots of girls, but there is just one us. You make me feel like I'm a real man. All around the world there's lots of girls but there is just one us. You make me flip your loves a trip and I won't miss that bus. I don't need no plan B, no plan B, I don't need no plan B. Yeah, yeah, there's other fish in the sea, but you're the only one for me.
骑车时，头上不戴头盔，因为我更喜欢戴这顶假发。我意识到我可不是什么马修·麦康纳。我从肯尼亚飞往英国。世界各地有很多女孩，但我们只有一个。你让我觉得自己是个真正的男人。世界各地有很多女孩，但我们只有一个。你让我觉得你的爱是一场美妙的旅程，我绝不会错过那辆车。我不需要什么B计划，不需要B计划，我不需要什么B计划。是的，是的，天涯何处无芳草，但你是我唯一的挚爱。
I don't need no plan B, no plan B. I got my eggs in one basket, my money in one place. Every day's fantastic, because I get to see your face. But I know what's on your mind, stupid, Steve, and Stanley. Forget those other guys, you don't need no plan B, you don't need no plan B Yeah, I can't, there's other fish in the sea But surely all they want for me, you don't need no plan B You don't need no plan B, you don't need no plan B
我不需要什么B计划，不需要B计划。我的鸡蛋都放在一个篮子里，钱都存在一个地方。每一天都妙不可言，因为我能见到你的脸。但我知道你在想什么，笨蛋，史蒂夫和斯坦利。忘掉那些家伙吧，你不需要什么B计划，你不需要什么B计划。是的，我知道，天涯何处无芳草，但他们对我的渴望不过如此，你不需要什么B计划。你不需要什么B计划，你不需要什么B计划。
You don't need no plan B, you don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don need a landing, I don need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don need a landing, I don need a landing, I don need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don't need a landing, I don Thank you. Thanks so much for doing this. Thanks for having me. The Hidden Brain Podcast is produced by Karam Agurkallisin and Machia Penman, special thanks this week to Adam Cole. You can find more of Adam at Sculk Bear on YouTube and Tumblr. Before I let you go, I'm wondering if you can do something for me. Can you let me know what you think of the podcast so far, what segments work for you? Email us at HiddenBrain at NPR.org or find a survey on our Facebook page. Until next week, I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR.
你不需要什么B计划……谢谢。非常感谢你做这些。谢谢邀请我。本期《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉姆·阿古尔卡利辛和马基亚·彭曼制作，本周特别感谢亚当·科尔。你可以在YouTube和Tumblr的Sculk Bear上找到更多关于亚当的内容。在我放你走之前，我想知道你能为我做件事吗。你能告诉我你目前对这个播客的看法吗？哪些环节对你有用？给我们发邮件到HiddenBrain@NPR.org，或者在我们的Facebook页面上找一份问卷。直到下周，我是香卡·韦丹坦，这里是NPR。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。